Okay. So, um, just want to
go back very briefly, um,
to, um, uh, approach to
as I lay dying last time,
we talk about the importance
of the epic tradition, uh,
to the modern, this novel,
uh, and the way that,
especially the way that
the voice dead and I'm the,
and suddenly the boundaries between
the human and the nonhuman are being
reactivated and redeployed
in as I lay dying.
Uh, so today we're going to move on to
a somewhat different approach to this is
really a different way to
contextualize, uh, as I lay dying.
And, uh, it's more of a kind of
an American, uh, tradition, uh,
for this novel. And in fact, we
really began to see a law that, um,
in the person, uh, who, um, is
in one sense a key player. Uh,
but in another sense, not, um,
the eddies partner in the
adulterous affair and,
uh, Faulkner, uh,
text the name of that person from a
historic figure that's very well known.
Preacher 18th century
preacher George Whitfield,
someone who actually has a very large
presence and Benjamin Franklin's
autobiography. So this is the
very dignified looking, uh,
historical George with Phil.
And this is farmers with Phil.
Uh,
when he was on his horse, he was able
to cross the river as we know, uh,
and he's on his way. In fact, he's
approaching his right at the house.
So, um, with feel, um, has a lot of,
has lots to be thankful for.
And his expressing his
gratitude to God at this moment.
It was here in his infinite wisdom that
restrained the tail from her dying lives
as she lays around by those
who loved and trusted her mind.
The travail by water,
which I sustained by the strength of his
hand praise to the indiebound bandages
and omnipotent love. Oh, praise. Um,
yes. I mean he truly is a
very lucky guy. Um, you know,
issue dies before she was able to give
away his name and maybe she never,
plans are just too proud and was
the one to give away his name. Um,
so he's lucky and having chosen
the right partner, someone who,
who lives a seal when it
comes to his name. Um,
and he's also very lucky in the sense
that his horse is such a good swimmer of
that, um, is the horse, is able to
cross the river when the muse drown.
So, um, this is truly, um, you know,
he is truly a blessing figure it,
but of course I'm making fun of him as
I indeed I think Faulkner ones as to,
um, the only way I think to
take someone like with you, um,
is to put him in one particular genre.
And this is really what I liked to argue
today is the question of Java for as I
lay dying,
the only way to take with failed is
to put them in the genres of comedy.
And he's just a common figure. You
know, he's totally serious himself.
This congratulating himself
in his praising the Lord,
but all the time when he's doing that,
he's firmly and Scottish
in the comic tradition.
Um, and it turns out that this, um,
self congratulating self dignifying,
uh,
kind of person actually has a
president in American literature,
a very prominent president.
And it turns out there,
this predecessor is also a minister
who has an affair with a woman.
So we, you know, there's only one
novel, um, in American literature that,
um,
that is like that and not surprisingly
is a novel that we all recognize the
scarlet letter. Um, so
this is Hawthorne's, um,
comic figure.
Um,
skyline is not really usually
read as a comic novel,
but I do think that half of this having
fun when he's portraying other dems down,
God knows and he's merciful.
He have proof his mercy.
Most of all in my afflictions by giving
me this burning towards you or to bear
upon my breasts, praise be his
name, his will be done. Fair. Well,
same.
Exactly the same combination of woman
whose lips are sealed with never give away
the name of her partner.
Um,
and the same kind of mercy from
mercy in cohesion, miles from God.
Um, in this, in this case, um,
other than his name was lucky.
Not in the sense that he has a
horse or who's a good swimmer,
but in the sense that he dies
right at that moment. Um,
and so,
you know,
without in at the very moment when he's
thanking God and he is forgiven his
sense of a given, he dies. So he,
um, is very lucky in that way.
Um, and it, um,
suggest that from the very beginning,
from the 19th century on,
um, a story that otherwise
would have been taken as tragic.
Ashley has the comic dimension to it.
Um,
it's just not very easy to roll our eyes
when we listen to someone like with the
hill and when we listen to someone
like Arthur Dimmesdale. Um,
but even as we were rolling our eyes,
um,
I think that there are other things in
those two novels that is very hard too,
bro. Ally's over. So I want to
turn now to this other dimension,
um, and want to begin
with Hall thought, uh,
by talking about obviously the much
more important tragic dimension, um,
in the scarlet letter and his own has to
print the fact of the symbol or rather
of the position in respect to society
that was indicated by it on the mind of
Hester.
Prynne herself was powerful and peculiar.
All the light and graceful foliage of
her character had been weathered up by
this red hot brand and
had long ago fallen away,
leaving a bear and hush outline,
which might've been repulsive,
has sheet who says friends or
companions to be repelled by it.
So just as um,
Dimsdale and with feel a Aa lucky,
um,
has to print is doubly because,
uh,
she's caused both in the most obvious
way because she has to wear the scarlet
letter for the rest of her
life. Um, and she's also occurs,
well, she's actually AAA cause she
has to wear the scarlet leather.
Her whole being is transformed.
So all the beauty of physical beauty or
the beauty of her mind seemed to have
gone away. Um, and she is just,
it's very hush for building character.
Um,
and that other people might've found
repulsive if she had friends, uh,
to be repairable. So, you know,
really she is an absolute,
have not at this point or hold on,
as you guys know who read
the Scott Leather hold on
actually qualifies that this
isn't quite the absolute ending of
the sky. It's quite early. Um, so, um,
this is kind of low point, absolute
low point, the most tragic moment, uh,
for Hester in the sky ladder. And, um,
I want to turn now from,
from Hester to a comparable figure
in a thoughtless as I lay dying.
Um,
and obviously it is adding and she's
especially a tragic in relation to the two
men in her life. First
of all, a relation to,
uh,
with field.
Why waited for him in the woods
waiting for him before he saw me?
I would think of him as dressed in sin,
would think of him as thinking
of me as stressed. Also in sin,
he,
the more beautiful since the Garmin
wish here is changed for sin with send
defied, I would think of
the stand as gum and switch.
We would remove in ologist
shape and colors to terrible
blood to the Phalon echo
of the dead wood high in the air.
It was about as,
um,
joy is the discretion of any condoms,
romance.
It's not even the romance.
It's not adultery. There's no,
there's no sex obviously. And
as I lay dying, um, there's, um,
there's almost no love.
Um, it is just the,
the whole act itself is
causing the terrible blood
to the Phalon echo after dead
air. So it's, um, if,
if that is, you know,
it was hard to understand why anyone
would even want to do that if that is the
nature of the affair.
But that's how falconer would like us to
think of that affair between had a and
a and with you and we can almost to stay
was she would be so Phalon because the,
his, the fact that he's congratulating
himself and scanning himself.
Lucky at the moment of her death suggest
what kind of a lover he has been a,
so maybe it's not surprising that she
should've been salon all the way through.
Um,
and it is also the case that
she's Phalon for another reason.
Um, and maybe that's why she got into
the fair to begin with a relation to her
husband and I would think,
and why and why you answer.
I would think about his name until after
awhile I could see the word as a shape
of vessel. And I would watch
him liquefy and slow into it,
like cold molasses flowing out of the
darkness into the vessel until the jars to
four and motionless significant shape
profoundly without live like an empty
doorframe.
Um,
is the one of the most memorable
descriptions of a terrible marriage,
unbearable marriage. And
um, I think that there's,
that says it all. You know, it
doesn't exactly justify, uh,
eddies action is it needs
justify justification. Um,
but it really explains a lot.
Um,
and it is in contrast to that,
to that coal molasses in the jar that
all of a sudden we see another marriage
and perspective.
So just want to refresh your memory
about what we saw last time about toe and
Cora because it would take a tight
house for coral to hope Cora,
like a job and milk in the spring.
You've got to have the type jar
or you need a powerful spraying.
So if you have a big spring,
why,
then you have the incentive to have tight
wellmade jars because it is your milk
sal or not,
because you would rather have them know
that we're sour then to have that won't
because you are a man. Um, so you
know, it's not as spectacular.
Marriage was good marriage. Um, and
it's, um, a marriage that makes,
how have you like a man and
public core? Like a woman? Um,
I don't mean to be sexist.
Um, just, just the, um,
just the general description
of a good marriage. Um, so, um,
his, um, tell and Cora, um,
as a foil really, uh, to add a and,
and um,
so it seems that right now we've
seen adding mostly as a tragic,
they go right in relation
to her too, man. Um, and uh,
and as a kind of a descendant,
20th century descendant of Hesta Prin.
Um,
but given the residence halls on,
given that that's really a comic
domination, even in the most tragic tale,
we should foot wishing.
Be surprised that they would also be a
comparable comic dimension in SLA die as
well.
So I like to read the whole novel,
as in some sense kind of constant
negotiation between those two poles,
between a comic poke betraying comedy
on the one hand and tragedy, uh,
on the other. And we can see
the Karma that coming in, um,
in at relation to her son,
father man,
who's not quite fully
retarded as Benji is. Um,
the Faulkner is really interested in the
slightly retarded mind sort of farther
than seems to be an instance of that.
Uh,
and it comes on and statements
like my mother's a fish. Um,
I think that along with call me Ishmael,
my mother's is officials got through
one of the most famous lines in American
literature. Um, and so why does,
so this brings us back to the
human and the nonhuman. Um,
but it also now suggest another
dimension and the generic Dinesh and,
um, to, um, add a being a fish.
And it turns out that she's
not just any kind of a fish,
but she's a fish out of water,
which is,
I guess it calmed restatement
of the sense of desolation.
And the philosophy is,
um,
that she feels towards with
you and towards as, I mean,
it's exactly the same thing except it
when we say that she's a fish out of water
is a couple of completely
different style of connotations.
So this is vitamin reporting on this fish.
They,
uh, that he just picked up their fish
already dead, uh, that he's chopping up.
Um,
so,
and you clean it and says he
don't look around farming.
Oh, sorry. Um, this is this
Ashley. Um, this is dow reporting.
You clean it and said he did.
He don't look around father.
When comes back and picks up the fish,
it's lies out of his hands,
smearing wet dirt onto him
and flops down doing itself.
Get Mouth Garbo,
hide hiding into a dust.
Like it was ashamed of being dead like
it was in a hurry to get that again.
Um,
so along with the sens that at a is
a misfit is completely alone and by
yourself,
even in a marriage and even
in an adulterous affair, um,
there's this additional element
that she's ashamed of all of it.
And we can see that shame,
um,
in her reaction to,
uh, the horse that, uh,
Joe acquires writing, she's proud,
she is proud, was just also crying.
Um, and Dow realizes that, um,
that she's ashamed of her
deceit at that moment. Um,
so there's this terrible shame
that's going to accompany her, uh,
in her death.
Um,
and in the fish it comes out as the
fish being ashamed of being dead.
Um, even though there's is like
another condition that we could,
that we could help,
but nonetheless,
this fish seems really ashamed
of this elemental fact. Um,
and in contrast, I think
that actually just to, um,
stop for a moment, um, the fish actually
would be a great paper topic, um,
for, for, for your
final paper. Um, and uh,
it would bring Hemingway and thought no
together in a really interesting way.
Um,
so once again,
one of reemphasize how interesting
it might be to pick something that is
progress, a rope, you
know, now the key player,
but they're interesting entry
point into novels. So, um,
in thinking along those lines,
um,
we can go back to the
fish in, in our time. Um,
and it's dead fish too,
that fish. Um, but um,
but totally different set of connotations
that Hemingway, uh, brings to the debt.
Trout.
Nick cleaned them,
sledding them from the
vent to the tip of the jaw.
All the insides and the Gills
and tongue came out in one piece.
They were both males,
long gray,
white strips of no smooth and clean.
All the insides clean and
Compaq coming out all together.
So this is Hemingway's. I
do have a good death. Um,
is the depth of human
beings being actually, uh,
prefigure or maybe encoded
into this very clean,
very dignify death of the fish.
There's no way we can avoid dying.
Um,
but the least that we can ask for is
that we should die in a manner that is
fitting for us. Um, uh,
man of them that is commensurate
with the way that with live, um,
and the child has lived a very clean life,
is important where to Hemingway has
lived with very clean live in the water.
So it is fitting that the death
should be commensurate with that. Um,
and that is really a kind
of utopian moment, um,
in Hemingway and in contrast,
this dirt is fish out of water.
Being ashamed and being
ashamed into unto death, um,
is the dystopian moment in thougth nerve,
but it's also a comic moment as well.
So all I wish to say they're comedies
is obviously very complicated and packed
and you know, in many ways contradictory
phenomenon, um, in Faulkner.
Um, but I want, and it's with
that understanding, you know,
accommodating quotation lost in many
ways that I like to think about the whole
structure of as I lay dying,
um,
as a negotiation to
train comedy and tragedy.
And I like to bring up 3 cents of
terms that we've been talking about all
through the semester to see how comedy
and tragedy get mapped onto these terms.
One is the human and nonhuman that
we've been talking about last time. Um,
and then I want to bring
him in way back up.
It turns out that the two categories have
and have not set up by Hemingway will
be key actually in the rest of
the novels that we'll be reading.
So are we using half and have not,
um,
as key terms within the as very useful
and the lid they paradigm and uh,
related to those.
Um,
since we've been talking so much about
kinship beginning with the sound of the
fury and also now as I lay dying brothers,
uh,
who is a kid and who is a non kin.
Last time we saw the Jew is in danger
of being labeled non-kin by uh,
his brother Dao and by
his sister who do Dell.
So who is going to be a nom
kin at the end of this novel?
But first let's start out with the most
obvious comic future of as I lay dying,
which is the most conventional
and then happy ending in marriage.
Um, and if you guys haven't
gotten to that point, I apologize,
but there's no way to talk about it as
comedy without talking about the very
last thing that we see as I lay dying.
It is cash and Joel and vitamin and do
it our process kind of handle and proud
too with his teeth and all,
even as he wouldn't look at it.
I mean this is [inaudible] so,
um,
his wife isn't quite in the ground.
Um,
and um, this is a very fast mover. Um,
so he has acquired a new wife,
um,
and other possessions sessions as well
where he, his teeth. Um, and so on.
This is a new future, um, on ends. Um,
so this is the, the, the Susie
cliched ending, um, for comedy,
you've got to have a marriage and family
are very obligingly gives us a marriage
at the end of, as I lay dying. Um,
but we just know he's going
to qualify it in some fashion.
So right before we see,
uh,
ends with his new wife and
his teeth, his new teeth, um,
we see something else and that
is just taking one step back.
Who is the head.
Then we see it wasn't the grip
that made them look different.
It was this phase and jewel says
he's got the teeth. It was a flap.
It made him look a foot taller,
kind of holding his head up,
hand up and proud to,
and then we see her behind
him carrying the other grip,
kind of duck shape woman all dressed up.
And then I see that the grip she was
carrying was one of them that are raffle
phones.
It was a fact,
I'll shut up and pretty as a picture and
every time a new record with come from
the mail order and us setting in the
house and the window listening to it,
I would think what a shame Dow
couldn't be to enjoy it too.
So a lot of information is coming
at us at this and new teeth,
another possession, graffel
phone, grandma farm. Um,
and the new phenomenon of
records coming by mail order.
Um, this is truly the 20th century. Um,
even though they are still
views it. Third, we are firmly
in the 20th century. Um,
and the crucial detail at the end,
the Dow will be there
to enjoy the records.
So, um, we know right there, and
this is very end, this is to 60,
so we know already has had $2,
just repeating what we've
known prior to this moment. Um,
then this would be constituting
of the bumper, that family,
that one person is no longer
can no longer in that family.
So how does this happen?
Is what we need to find out and we have
to go back a few steps to find out how
it is that our guest excluded
from that family circle.
Um,
so,
but just want to give you a couple of
images why the gramophone would be such a
desirable object, just like the
telephone, all this new equipment,
um, just incredibly glamorous
when they first appear. Um,
so Columbia gramophone
and um, and I like to, um,
since we have all this
desirable objects here, um,
is obviously as I lay dying is Faulkner's
version of to have and have not.
And right there we know that ends
has three very prize possessions,
teeth, wive and gramophone. Um,
and it seems that in contrast,
other people have all lost something.
They all have been,
uh, reclassified in some sense as, um,
have nots. So in many ways, this
was not a zero sum game, uh,
in,
uh,
as I lay dying that one person gets a
lot of stuff at the expense of someone
else is a fairy,
a steer and economic model
that there's no view. Again,
in this world someone gained
something, someone loses something. Um,
and the three people who lose something
in the course of ns acquiring.
So much of the history sounds cass,
jewel and out.
Um, so let's just look at cash. Um, and I,
I can,
you know,
this is not really related to
anything that I've been saying so far,
but you know,
there's clearly cash and Geo caches,
the petty cash and jewel is the one
whose value cannot be a wreck by cash.
So fall is really playing with
the economic model in a big way.
So maybe it's not surprising that,
you know,
it would also be a kind of equal on
economic logic that's determining the
narrative logic. And as I
lay dying as well, but um,
cash been named after the petty
cash. Here's one who would, um,
go try and make $3 a
tourism now seeing his, his,
his mother when she dies, not being
with his mother when she dies. Um,
so petty cash,
um,
but even though he is being
is measure by petty cash,
um,
even in spite of the heat doesn't,
can always hold on to what he has low
as what he does have initially starting
out.
His face turned up a second when
he was sliding back into the water,
it was gray with his eyes closed and the
long swipe of mud across his face that
he let go into her to
go over in the water.
He looked just like no bundle of clothes,
kind of washing up and
down against the bank.
He looked like it was laying
there in the water on his face,
rocking up and down low,
looking at something at the bottom.
Uh,
so cash is my mentality nonhuman.
He's lost his humanity. It looks
like a bundle of clothes. Um,
and um, and we can all do that. You know,
if we are floating in the
river, um, unconscious,
we can look like we are
in an intimate matter,
which is what cash is at this moment.
Um,
he could be in aliment Mather like a
Bumbo of old clothes or we can also think
about this in kind of kinship that is
snapping in place because we have Ashley,
um,
fall and make sure that we have vivid
memory of something else that also slow
that before live this in the
water between the two hills.
I see the muse once more,
they row up out of the water in succession
turning completely over the legs,
deflate extended as when they
had lost contact with the glove.
So the reuse of floating belly
up the legs stiffly extended,
um, best to kind of
unnatural postures for them.
And cash is floating face down while he's
looking at something at the bottom of
the river. Um, but either way,
the two pastures are almost
magical in the sense that uh,
both amused and cash are
reduced to inanimate matter,
um, in, in that kind of posture. Um, and,
um,
we know that the muse on
ambulance photo and, um,
they also emblems for
it's not cow is cash. Um,
is, is for, for caches. Um, kinship, uh,
that he too is a creature a
with feet of clay. And so,
um, this is really FMA reaffirming, um,
the fact that he's not capable of lots of
things. It's a very good carpenter, um,
based,
not capable of surviving in hostile
environment and water is one of them.
Um, so, um,
he right there is just that
kinship as being a reaffirm,
but we can also see Tash as an
ironic instance of a half as well.
Um,
and this is something that we actually
come into play in a big way and the last
Hemingway novel,
um,
that in fact it comes into play
in to Hemingway novels. Um,
I promise you that this ironic use
of the hat will be a central moment,
um, in for whom devout hose. But looking
back, so we have that to go forward to.
Uh, but we can also look back to
an earlier moment in half and half,
not when Harry Morgan is
dying. Uh, his unconscious.
Um, and he feels that his, this
rubber hose inside of him. Right.
So when we're talking about that moment,
um,
I was suggesting a, although I
wasn't pushing very hard on that,
um, the, there was a
moment of an ironic have,
we don't actually have rubber
hoses inside our bellies, uh,
but they can sometimes feel that way.
Um, and so it's an ironic procession,
was very negative possession,
ironically vested in us. Um,
and here, um, it's the same
idea in thought leader.
Um,
cat as having an Iran,
they put stash and that is make tones
and into casualty as it did Harry Morgan
in to have and have not
cash has a broken leg.
He has had two broken legs.
He lies on the box with a quilt road on
his head and the peers who were under
his knee, I reckon we ought to
left him at arms dance palaces.
I haven't got a broken leg and par
hasn't and dial hasn't and it's just the
bumps catch says it's kind of
grinds together a little on a bum.
It don't bother them.
So far,
the man is the one who is speaking here.
Vitamin is really rubbing in that has,
has a broken leg.
He has had two in his life.
He's managed to break both of his
legs in his occupation as a carpenter,
fallen down from some hype,
uh, in this case, just, uh,
his leg is broken by a battery by,
by the Horse, um, and,
and the law. Um, so,
um, he, um, has, he does what he has.
He's lost his tools at this point.
He's lost his consciousness. Um,
he's lost his leg.
But what he has instead of a good life
is a broken leg that as well as in his
possession now. So it's definitely,
it's an ironic instance. Um, uh,
have an vitamin is very,
very glad that he doesn't have that.
I don't have that part, doesn't
have that. Dow doesn't have that.
So definitely it is at the verb to have,
um,
as alive though they, um, but we can also,
so that is an instance of
Errand Ising that thought,
but this also kind of a straightforward
instance of cash as a have not in a very
simple quantifiable way.
Um,
and actually quantification
is kind of interesting, um,
in thoughts on it as well.
If we think of the entire novel,
the whole narrative economy is kind of
zero sum game than actually quantifying
who gets what and measuring that against
who loses what actually this kind of
quantify logic going on in,
uh, it's already done. Um,
so this is of quantifying
moment. Um, and as I lay dying,
we know that the muse have drum,
so they have to get another team of news.
This is very few poor people,
that team of Muse with
cause flooding hours.
Um,
and it seems that ans actually has
managed to come up with the $40.
So Dow is trying to figure it
out where he got the $40 from.
So that's what you were doing.
And caches closed last night
down that cash aim to buy that.
Talking machine from Surat with that
money does that and stood there,
mumbling his mouth to watch him
be anything. Never blinked yet,
but that's just $8 more.
Does that and that voice,
like it was just listening and
never give him doing it himself.
That's the one by team as to look that
you quick kind of sliding his eyes that
way that he looked down again.
God knows if there was ever a man,
it says still,
they didn't say nothing.
They just watch him waiting and
him sliding his eyes to what?
The feed and out the legs.
But no, Ohio and the homeless,
he says,
so we know exactly what it takes to reach
that fully dollar mach is to get $10
from do doubt.
There's no time to talk about that.
It's just straightforward.
She was $10, um,
for the left to fill your abortion
and he got the $10 from her.
Um,
and um,
he gets $8 from a cash it gas was
going to use that to buy a telephone.
Um,
that's very far from that goal.
$40.
So one very valuable thing has to be
traded in order to him to get to $40.
And there's just one thing left is the
most obvious item that is in anyone's
possession. Um, so we can
turn now to, you know, uh,
Jews, horse obviously is
key from beginning to end.
Um,
but I just,
since we've been talking about
kinship between humans and animals,
I just want to stop very briefly and,
and once again,
hold on the conjecture but I think that
was [inaudible] is in here is in some
ways taking this back to the moment when,
um,
is both a horse and the snake,
right?
You talked about that last time
that he's caught between two posts.
His both a horse bill also does
something snake like about his movement.
Um,
and it seems that that association with
the snake has been reinvested in ads.
So we have the image of him
repeated twice as lightning,
his eyes to Sgo,
sliding his eyes to a
defeat and up the legs,
but no higher.
It is not sliding motion that realize
the human nonhuman configuration in as I
lay dying.
So that it is,
and who is the snake in the family.
Um,
and it's as a jewel has suddenly been
free from his kinship with the snake.
Cause someone else, maybe there's
just, this is also a zero sum game.
There's only one person in a family
who could claim kinship with the snake.
And as right here is claiming
kinship with the snake.
So Joe is going to relinquish
his friend, his kingship, um,
and be redefined in a
different way. So, um, but the,
just to wrap up with cash is lost $8.
Once again,
true to his name. That's what he
loses. Still a very [inaudible].
Uh, but this is the big loser. Um,
and he has that margin is per
session so he can afford to lose big.
Um,
but let's start out with an image of
Geo as still a half still having that
thing. Uh, when, um,
it's clear that when it, the emergent
situation is becoming clear to everyone.
Um,
it is jewel that as is looking at,
and Joe has not reacted in any fashion.
So this is a true,
um,
turning point where things
or have a moment of critical
moment when things could
have gone either way. Right? So the
horse is still in Jews possession.
Um, he doesn't have to
give up. The horse is,
would be impossible for as to take control
of the horse is the last person to be
able to control that wild horse. Only
one person can control that whole list.
Joe.
So this is a critical moment.
How is as going to be able to get a
hold of the host to sell the horse?
Um,
and it seems as if Julie has
really tended in one direction,
this is a route that he could have taken,
but I'm giving it away in the sense
that no, is the road not taken,
but this is the one when we looked like
this was row that he's about to take a,
so as soon as Joe here is
that, you know, it was,
the horse is part of the Bhag and um,
then it's spit slow and said hell,
he turned and went onto the gate
and on the, the Horse in God on it,
they went outside that way.
The two of them looking like some kind
of spot is cycling still true to that
original image of
incredibly fast movement,
almost super human in the speed
with which the two of them move.
And also so the human,
almost mythic in a sense that man and
horse and become one does the Hemingway,
um,
image that is transposed onto fallen
since the closest the farmer has worked
ever get to Hemingway is Jew
and the horse becoming one. Um,
so it looks like that,
you know,
answers never gonna be able to get $40,
because Joe and hosts had cleared out.
Um,
do you can still be a have if
this were the ending of Sally die,
this is what happens after that.
The horse I said and answers boy taking
that horse and clean out last night,
probably halfway to Texas by now. And
as, I don't know who Brung it used to,
said I never see them. I just found
the Horse in the barn this morning.
They went to few,
uh,
told Mr snoops he said to
bring the team over here.
So the team of mew arrives because Mr
Snow's did get the whole list and only one
person could have brought
the horse to Snopes. So,
um, jus becomes, I have not,
when we can see why he's losing his
kinship to the snake is becoming,
have not by voluntarily like
relinquishing his possession of the horse.
He is the most tragic
figure. He one says, uh,
because he has the most power to refuse
to live, relinquish that procession.
And he is the one who actually our
office power actually willfully,
deliberately,
consciously gives up that possession.
Um, so, um, it,
the time has come for remapping of
the whole tennis ship structure.
Um,
and as I lay dying,
Gio has up to this point being
been the outsider to the family.
Here's the one that everyone picks out
as being a non-kin by Dow and by do
doubt.
Um,
but this is the moment when all of a
sudden he's been admitted for the first
time into the family circle and was
interesting is that this will join of the
kinship lies is dramatize by Faulkner as
through racialization of both cash and
kill. And we can stay why they are both
racialized at this critical moment.
They become chin because
they both become black.
Kansas leg and foot turned black.
He held the lamb and look at caches
for and like where it was black.
You full, it looks like
a negative. His foot cat,
I said Ju was lying on
his back on his face.
His bag was rare.
Do they'll put the medicine on it.
The Madison was made of butter
and stood to draw the fire.
Then his back was black.
Does it hurt you? I said,
your back looks like a niggers
Joe as that Cassius foot.
And like look like a negatives.
This is really heavy handed a father.
They both look like niggers.
Um,
and for two different
reasons. Um, caches, foot,
um,
is turning black because they
put concrete on it by two
sinks, the leg does this fix
the broken leg, the abundance,
I put concrete on it.
That's the way of,
that's the medical practice
within the bundle and family.
So his foot is turning
black at this moment. Um,
and Jews,
um,
back is whack because he'd
just been in the fire.
He's the one who actually safe the coffin.
Others dubious thing to do.
He's the one who actually saved the coffin
when the bottom was selling fire. Um,
and as a consequence again,
he gets this severe burn on his back
and that's why his back is all black.
So each of them, Ashley, um,
has lost something and they gain
something. They don't have a normal color,
like have a normal color back.
They've gone,
they've gained a black
legging and plan back, um,
and is in as a result of,
you know,
being black and in this manner and all
of a sudden they become brothers. So,
um,
this is a new concept of brotherhood.
Uh,
and new membership been proposed
for that kinship structure.
Uh,
Joe,
who's previously been outside of that
cancer can shift circle has been a minute
and we'll see who is going to be
excluded once again to sales game.
You know, someone has been learning, um,
who is it and for what reason
is he going to be left out?
It wasn't nothing else to do.
It was either send him to Jackson or
have to Massbay sewers because he knows
some way the dowel set fire to it.
So everything is interlocking and father
it is that fire than turns Jews back
into a black back.
And the same fire also has
consequences for other people.
You don't set fire to the bond
without someone paying for it.
And it turns out that it is, uh,
who is going to be here for it.
And the language that is used
here, this is cash. Who's speaking,
I'm still in the voice of someone who's
used to being helpless and used to not
being able to modify the situation that
is given this just nothing else to do.
One person has to take the blame and
to take the consequences of that blame.
So one person has to be sent to Jackson.
And we know what Jackson is in already
has been looming presence and the sound
of the theory as the ultimate for bed Jay.
Um,
and it is actually the home for,
for down much sooner than
it will be for Benji.
So let's look at two instances of the
reconstituted of the narrowing of the
kinship circle and cash,
uh,
talking now and looking
at his brother Dao,
but beginning to see
his brother as a non-kin
when doubt this is kept
speaking. Um, and his actually,
his sort of agrees with Dow that might
maybe is a good thing to burn up the cart.
And you know,
it's just so humiliating for adding to
be smelling and other buses descending on
her. You know, they keep counting 10,
and then more and more. Um, and everyone,
all the towns, they go through, uh,
wanting to sue them because
of the terrible smell that
is coming from the coffin.
Um, so because of this other humiliation
that's been visited upon hourly,
it would have been a good
thing to burn up the coffin.
And because it wasn't going to happen and
nobody else was going to do at Dow was
going to do it. So cash can see the
reason for wanting to burn up the coffin,
but he can also see that maybe is not
such a great thing for the person who was
doing it.
When Dalcin that look like one
of us would have to do something,
I can almost believe
he done right in a way,
but I don't reckon nothing.
Excuses setting fire to man's bond and
endangering his stock and destroying his
property. That's how I reckon
recommend man is crazy.
That's how I can see eye to eye.
That's how he can see eye
to eye with other folks.
And I reckon the end,
nothing else to do with him.
But what the most folks says is right.
So
cash ceiling,
his bond with Dow as Dow,
his brother,
the kids should bond is superseded by a
much more clearcut [inaudible] relation
is you down really has no relation to Joe
sp other than that he is the destroyer
of Gillespies property,
but it is the destroyer of gymnastics
property that he will get sent to Jackson.
Is that impersonal?
Their relationship,
they were defined down in the hand
and not his kinship with his brother.
Two brothers. Um, so
this is the exclusion,
the beginning of the exclusion and
the lodging for that exclusion, uh,
of Dow from their family circle.
Um,
but it is vitamin who puts the
case most strongly and clearly
fallen in talking about
that he went to Jackson,
he went crazy and went to Jackson.
Both lots of people didn't go crazy pie
in cash and Joe and do thou in me then
go crazy. We never did go crazy. We
didn't go through Jackson leader.
This is a child. He's still clueless,
but he's also the most ominous,
um,
that the family from now on is going
to be part and cash and jewel and do it
out.
And me father man is not going to include,
I think work's been radically
reconstitute it. Um,
and it is on the basis of that
reconstitution that we can think about,
uh, as behalf not as the, that have not,
I think Dow and jewelers and metrical
that Science Joe has given up the thing
that is most monitoring
monetarily valuable and he's
given up the thing that is
most humanly valuable.
Dal has gone to Jackson.
This is Dov speaking and then speak
referring to himself in the third person
talking about himself as in the third
person that has gone to Jackson,
they put him on another train
laughing down a long car, current law,
laughing and has turning the
heads of hours when he passed.
What are you laughing at?
I said, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Dow is our brother, our brother Dao. Oh,
brother Zhao in occasion,
Jackson where his grime has blind with
light in the is looking out his phones.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
So he's lost his mind.
That's what there is to lose
in the cause of this novel.
He has lost his family. We
know that. That's one of the,
uh,
nonmonetary things that can also be
lost as lost as brothers is lost.
Everything is lost,
his freedom.
And he also has lost his mind.
So we can really think of a darker,
and then this,
and it says a lot about Faulkner,
that this dockers of endings is
Ashley stuck in the middle of a story.
They actually, as a comic, and they, and
that's what fat does. What John does.